Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill burn it's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
October 3rd,
2016 what's going on?
How are Ya?
Oh Shit.
Wait a minute.
Today was supposed to be the fucking first day,
the pink football and I didn't see any of that shit out there.
Did they abandon it?
Did I dream that it went away?
Uh,
that's,
they probably walked away.
Too many people getting wise.
They made their money.
The old filthy stinking NFL snuck away.
Okay.
The all their pick money to raise awareness.
Uh,
yeah.
You know,
we'll fuck,
you know,
we made our fucking money off of it.
We'll,
uh,
we'll,
maybe there's,
I don't know.
I should as I thought it was in October,
isn't that when the,
the pink lady takes it and all that money because everybody's suffering fucking
asshole to buy herself a pink yacht.
Isn't that how it works?
You know?
And then everybody walks around with a little fucking pink,
a pocket square or some shit.
Let's take a moment of silence to listen to all the money that is not going
towards the disease.
We all think we're trying to fight right now.
Jet's Passover.
Fucking somebody eat some fucking cotton candy.
Yay.
And onto the games.
Um,
all right.
I'm not going to be like this.
Okay.
It's Sunday when I'm recording this.
I just got back from a a fun weekend.
I did two nights in Madison,
Wisconsin.
And uh,
then I did a Gig in Omaha,
Nebraska.
Went to the corn huskers game verse a Illinois,
which is a great time,
legendary,
legendary football stadium.
Can't believe I finally got there back in the day.
I used to do,
so I'm going to actually talk to my agent because I used to do so many fucking
college gigs back in the day when I was coming up.
And then somewhere along the line,
you know,
you get a following and then you just go to the city and you've,
you either go to the club or if you're lucky you go to a theater or some shit.
And I'm somewhere along the line,
I just Kinda,
I got out of doing,
I want to get back to doing that shit.
But all I remember was I did a Zillion fucking colleges in Nebraska and Kansas.
I was forever flying into,
into fucking Kansas City.
And driving out to Hays is Hayes.
Nebraska is a key.
Is it haze?
Can I can't even remember.
Dodge city,
grand junction.
I can't eat.
I can't remember the names of it was so fucking long ago.
I just remember when you got on the 80 in Nebraska.
Jesus Christ clear.
You're going to scratch the whole podcast buddy.
Huh?
Let me help you with,
let me help you with that.
It's under your collar.
I've got you.
I got you.
I got to do it.
If there it is all look at that face and when they stick their face subtle
little further.
Oh,
that's the spot.
There it is.
Good.
All right,
great.
Okay.
Anyways,
Jesus,
go on.
Go down,
go lay down.
Go on,
go on.
Um,
so you go across the,
uh,
the 80,
um,
you get about halfway across the state and there was this weird like a fucking
footbridge with just go across this highway and,
um,
major highway.
I mean basically take that thing.
I all the way out to San Francisco.
If you go west and I think it,
uh,
I don't know where the hell that went dies.
I drove the 70 the whole way that one dies.
Some I drove it from like picked it up and like Utah offer the 15 drove the 70
all the way into like fucking Pennsylvania,
like a madman.
I would tell you that I drove cross country and like three and a half days by
myself with all my shit in my car,
my big square fucking TV,
you know,
parking next to f,
in parking lots sleeping would even get a fucking hotel room.
I got a hotel room one night,
but then I had to like pick the fucking TV up and take it in and it was just a
pain in the ass.
So I was just like,
yeah,
fuck it.
The next night I slept in the car anyways.
I drove like a fucking lunatic,
like 70,
80 miles an hour the whole way there.
And um,
didn't get pulled over until I got to the George Washington bridge.
And that's what I got pulled over and the cop came up to window and go,
you know,
it's funny,
I drove here all the way from day.
I do think guy just shut the fuck up.
Give me if
he didn't,
he didn't.
He didn't give a shit about how I thought it was a funny little moment.
You know,
I just drove fucking 2,500 miles and I didn't have a problem and I got down to
the last three miles of my trip and a then I'm getting a ticket and this,
this man did not give a shit and he gave me a ticket sell.
Anyways,
I had done a bunch of college kids out there.
So throughout the years,
that's how I went to all the baseball stadiums,
football and all that shit when I was on the road.
And uh,
every fucking time I would be anywhere near Nebraska if they had a game,
it was always at night or if they had a game,
they were on the road and I was never able to go.
So fortunately I finally got to go and um,
it was pretty cool,
actually.
Met Larry the cable guy there.
I had never met him.
I've seen him blow up throughout the years and uh,
got to hang out with him and he's like the fucking president out there.
So like they had like all their Heisman trophy winners were there that day.
So Mike Rozier came in and actually got a picture with him and Larry the cable
guide photo bombed it in the background.
I was there with Nate Craig.
We had a great fucking time.
I'm so thanks to Larry for letting us in to his,
uh,
his,
his fucking,
whenever you called the living room,
the suite there,
it was just great.
But anyways,
the stadium was amazing.
Those people are fucking loud too.
That wasn't like the most riveting game either.
Like the first half.
Of course,
the part that I saw before to drive back up to Omar,
um,
kind of sucked.
And it also,
it really sucked because I bet Nebraska and they were given 20 and a half points
in the halfway through the second quarter.
I'm just thinking,
why the fuck
would I give 20 and a half points to Lovie Smith,
this guy,
this guy fucking coach in the NFL,
sorry,
I'm Yonah here,
guide,
coach in the NFL for like,
I don't know how many goddamn years now he's at the college level.
You're going to give,
I'm going to give this guy 20 and a half fucking points.
And Larry kept going.
I don't worry about it,
don't worry about it.
We,
we've,
we've scored more points of the fourth quarter than anybody else.
And they actually came back and they made it close.
But uh,
by then I was long gone and uh,
we drove up and had a great show in Omaha,
which I've never done a gig there.
I've landed at that fucking airport a zillion times,
but I've never,
um,
never did like an adult show.
There was always like a college show.
So,
um,
that was,
it was just a great fucking weekend.
But I come home today,
I came home really early cause I want to come home,
watch the Patriots,
see if we could go for now.
And I knew this was going to be a tough game.
Toughest game.
Cause Rex Ryan really gets up for the fucking patriots and Bill Bellacheck and
all that.
And uh,
we got a butts kit.
Basically we lost on all levels how offensive line couldn't protect,
uh,
whoever the fuck's our quarterback,
NC state guy there that our asses kicked on special teams
and you know,
when you keep going three now and get defense is going to get tired.
But I got to tell you something after all of that bullshit to only lose 16 to
nothing.
I was pretty happy with that.
And now fucking what's his face?
Tom Brady's back.
So it's over.
It's fuck it over.
The whole fucking thing is behind us now.
You know,
I was worried.
What if we go on for,
you know,
one in three would soc two and two it'd be great.
Three one would be ridiculous for no is like fucking a possum when we have,
we went three and one and then meanwhile the cry baby colts.
Oh,
you with
too squishy,
right.
Those fucking cunts went one in three.
Those fucking conch flew to the other side of the world to get their ass as well
by the fucking Jacksonville Jaguars.
You know what?
And in the end,
all of this bullshit,
the Patriots,
it's three one the culture one and three are the football gods have spoken
fucking horse shit.
Dumb is fucking most pathetic as fuck it every,
every fucking drives me nuts.
I keep saying I'm going to stop talking about it.
Keep going up.
And I just,
I keep looking up the colts and all the fucking shit that they did and just
nothing.
They get nothing.
Suck for luck.
Remember that.
Let's tank a whole fucking football season.
Been able to luck wishes they didn't do that,
huh?
Anyways,
so it's all back to normal and you guys can all fuck a relax because I'm never
going to talk about this again.
I'm never going to trash.
Germer Jimmerson again.
I make a promise.
I promise you guys that I will go at least
I'd say 30 minutes until the next podcast,
before I trashed them enough.
I don't know.
Whatever the next fucking things he does,
I'll fucking trash him again.
But,
uh,
I'm just like Tom Brady's coming back,
coming back against a Cleveland,
which is a decent team.
It's where fucking check.
Use the coach and,
um,
and they let them go.
They fired bill Belichick.
Ah,
who know,
who know?
Um,
did anybody watch the I that Clemson fucking Louisville Gay men?
That was,
I was on stage when I was in Omaha,
so I missed the first half,
but I,
I came back about midway through the third quarter.
What a fucking unbelievable game.
Um,
I also Miss Tennessee.
Tennessee had like,
if it wasn't for the clubs of Louisville game,
basically he had the game a week to two weeks in a row.
I think they're undefeated at foreign.
Oh,
a five.
[inaudible]
two and own EFCC um,
just a bunch of great games and I got to talk to people like my people.
All right.
People in Massachusetts,
people in New York,
places where I've lived,
those are pro football city cities.
I'm telling you,
you're fucking missing out.
I feel bad for you if you're not into college football.
I understand if you're married,
you got kids and at some point you got to take them out for a fucking ice cream.
I get that.
But,
um,
you're,
you're fucking mix of missing out.
I would just say just pick a fucking team.
You know,
I was never like a BC eagles fan.
I just know I liked,
I liked Boston University and a football team.
Uh,
you know,
it doesn't exist anymore for whatever fucking reason.
I don't know what happened.
I used to go to those games when I was a kid in Nicus and field there,
um,
where I also went and I saw a USFL game.
I saw the Boston breakers first,
the Washington federals.
We won,
of course.
And the place was packed too.
Um,
I dunno.
So just pick a fucking team.
Just pick a teen to fall.
Don't be a Douche and pick Alabama,
but you got to pick somebody competitive or you're not going to get into it.
So I picked Lsu and I'm going to see Lsu,
uh,
next week when they play Florida.
And,
uh,
I don't know that it's going to be a weird,
I hope that game doesn't suck.
I didn't see how Lsu did this week,
but I know that they fired less in their fucking offensive coordinator.
So
it's kind of crazy to do that in the middle of a fucking season.
I've never really seen that before.
But anyways,
I made an ass of myself as always when I,
when I landed in Nebraska because we had to get up at seven in the morning
cause I thought the fucking game was at 1230.
I don't know if when I was out here when I bought the tickets,
if it just said,
uh,
he was just doing like Pacific coast time cause we're,
we,
we're two hours behind him.
I don't know why you would do that.
So I thought the game was at 1230 so I've got like 7:00 AM flights out of
fucking a Madison,
Wisconsin connect in Chicago O'hare,
which is always a nightmare,
you know that fucking airports like nine miles long.
Um,
so we fucking,
we connect there and then we land.
And,
and what I got off,
I was so fucking tired and I had gone out the night before like a fucking
asshole.
And when I landed,
I saw this kid when I was going to the rental car place,
he had this Kansas Jayhawks shirt on.
And uh,
I've always loved Kansas is,
I don't know why I was one year.
I just,
as I started watching them,
um,
I just liked him,
you know,
and,
uh,
so I've always wanted to go to the field house and everything.
So I saw it.
I was like half asleep and I was just like,
oh shit,
Kenzie Jay Hawks Fan.
He goes,
yeah,
I go,
they play in Lincoln or Omaha.
Like I wasn't even thinking like in the kids,
like,
uh,
they play in Lawrence,
Kansas,
and I just walked away and I was so fucking tired.
It didn't even hit me till Nate started laughing at me.
I was like,
oh my God,
he's gonna think I'm a fucking idiot.
He was a good,
I listen to the podcast and everything.
I was just like,
oh yeah,
kids is,
do they play in Nebraska?
That's basically what I said to him and he just sort of looked at me like,
ah,
no.
He probably walked away like,
wow,
that really isn't an act.
He really is that fucking stupid.
Um,
so anyways,
I want to read this,
this thing to you.
This is one of my favorite things that I've seen in a while.
Um,
the Ryder Cup in Golf.
All right,
I'm sorry that this is all fucking sports.
You know,
I could talk Trump for a second if you want to.
What does this horse shit that they get the guy's fucking tax information.
Somebody sent that in.
All right.
I love everybody go,
oh somebody,
somebody that works from sends it in now why aren't they being prosecuted for
something?
You just can't take somebody who's fucking tax refund and send it in.
And then the fucking,
they all they got is like,
they got like one year of his shit or something like that and they just looked
at it and he'd,
he claimed a fucking 900 something million dollar loss when his casino went out
of business or something like that.
And then they go,
um,
and he legally found these loopholes.
Keyword there is legal.
So I don't understand.
And I fucking can't stand the guy and I'll,
and I'll tell you I'm not,
I'll tell,
I'll tell you,
I'm not voting for that fucking guy.
I'm not voting for fucking Hillary there and fuck all you cuts ago.
Ooh,
you don't vote for Hillary.
I was like,
well,
the Trump,
go fuck yourself.
It isn't,
I want to try to find somebody,
you know,
that's,
I dunno,
remotely fucking honest,
to try to encourage more honest people to run for this fucking office.
I just don't understand all the policies out there.
They're just cave and go,
these are our two choices.
I'll just fucking pick one of these in,
in,
you know,
I think they'd like to keep writing,
I guess is his guy,
Gary Johnson.
People are freaking out about like,
he's the next fucking great white hope,
you know that right.
He's going to somehow stop the bankers,
right.
Or some shit.
And,
uh,
so they keep writing these fucking articles cause they're,
they're worried that they just make the assumption that if you would,
if you didn't vote for Gary Johnson,
that you would vote for,
um,
what's her face?
Oh,
crooked fucking,
uh,
Kathy there.
Hillary Clinton.
I hate when they do that.
Like they don't understand what people are doing when they vote for,
uh,
a third option.
You know what I mean?
It's you saying,
fuck these two people and fuck both those political parties.
They just always assume that when you go that to that third party that you're
really a democrat.
Like there's no republican out there sitting there going,
there's no fucking way I could vote for Trump or Hillary.
You know what I mean?
I Dunno.
Anyways,
let's,
uh,
but the guy fucked like somebody swipes his fucking tax return that can't be
fucking legal.
I don't think this guy has it laying around somebody.
It's from 1995.
Somebody obviously snoop and for the fucking thing,
like basically there was a legitimate crime committed.
The New York Times looks at his fucking tax refund.
All they can say is that he legally found loopholes so great.
So then he didn't cheat on his taxes.
MMM.
I don't know.
Like,
like the fucking Clinton's pay taxes.
What the fuck are they doing?
Throw their daughter a $3 million fucking wedding.
You get the best.
The most money Bill Clinton ever made was 400 grand a year fucking as president
until he started giving all those speeches to the constant funded them.
They washed all that bribe money.
They're all filthy.
Oh,
I'm the angry voter.
I'm going to write in my dog.
I hate when people,
now that's,
that's thrown you fucking vote away.
Like everybody in Washington goes,
wow,
this guy was so fed up.
He wrote his dog's name.
It guys,
I think we all need to stop and figure out what we're doing.
Clia.
Why are you so itchy?
Cleo?
Did you get into something
stark?
We got this great backyard is a waiting for the fucking kitchen and get done.
Did I tell you guys what happened?
Did he tell you when they went to the floor with the fuck they found?
Uh,
that's not going to make it go an extra two fucking weeks.
Um,
and we don't have this place as long as that.
So I think I'm going to be staying in a fucking hotel.
It's just,
I don't know why we did it.
I mean,
I was kind of all for,
hey,
why don't we just stay in the house until it catches on fire and when the cloth
wiring flashes or whatever the fuck it does and just burns the whole thing down,
we just walk away from this.
Would that be great?
Do you ever think of how fucking great having everything you own just burned to
the fucking ground.
As long as you got some money in the bank,
obviously if you don't have the money in the bank that would be fucking,
but if you just get you to your work and
okay,
you just walk away from all of it,
right?
No more trips to goodwill,
right.
No more.
Nothing sentimental that you just can't get rid of anymore.
It's just all you got the fucking shirt on your back.
You like fucking Johnny Appleseed.
You know,
I've got to tell you,
the longer I live,
the more urge I have.
Like I was out in Nebraska and I was fucking in like Wisconsin and I was
envious.
I was like,
look at all this fucking space these people have,
who is trees other than they have,
they have water.
Shit doesn't just catch on fire on his shirt.
They got them tornadoes out there,
you know.
But uh,
I went down this road when I was in Wisconsin,
I swear to God,
it's like one of those roads that they shoot a car commercial one.
And I was just out there like in Nebraska going this right here,
this is where you could actually,
you could,
you could have a fast car,
you could write a fucking motorcycle and that worry that someone's going to
fucking kill you every three seconds.
You could actually get your car,
you know,
up to 80,
90 miles an hour out here.
La,
you got to try to do it at three in the morning and you get on the fucking
highway.
And that's the only time those poor baskets can try to fix the fucking thing.
So then they have it all go down to one lane and you're sitting in traffic in at
three in the morning.
Um,
so it's beautiful.
I fucking love Wisconsin,
man.
I'm a big fan of Milwaukee too.
Um,
and Nebraska was the shit and uh,
I dunno,
I think I would slowly,
you know,
he would go crazy.
My wife would go crazy if I,
if I brought her up there,
first focus should probably be like one of the only black people in fucking
Nebraska.
But,
but I would also be able to leave,
you know,
I could fly around and go do gigs and go to a big city and then fucking come
back,
you know,
be hilarious then.
Then she'd want to be a road dog with me.
Like then she'd be all excited.
Where are you going?
I want to go.
Cause like,
I don't know if you guys noticed,
but Nia never goes on the road with me unless I go,
I'm going.
If I go to Miami,
all of a sudden she wants to support me because I get lonely out there.
If I go to New York City,
anytime I leave the country,
you know,
but when I really fucking need her,
when I'm fucking going to,
I don't know,
going out to El Paso or some shit like that,
but I can't even say that because I had a great time when I was there.
That's the fucking thing.
When I go on the road,
I whatever people do,
I,
I just people,
there's no way.
People just sit around not having fun.
They're going to figure out how they're going to have fun.
You just got to figure out where the fuck it is.
And uh,
you know,
who knows?
Next thing you know,
you're in Jacksonville,
Florida at a fucking gun range,
shooting a gun with a silencer actually got to fucking do that.
And everybody,
whenever they bring up Jacksonville,
oh my God,
there's nothing there.
All I think about a feeling like I was in the secret service,
right?
Right.
Cleo,
when those James Bond fucking movies,
they was a disappointing sound by the way.
Um,
the silencer,
it didn't have that cool fucking movie sound like it was like,
it didn't sound like that.
It a,
a metal clanky sound.
It was really quiet.
If you're a light sleeper,
you'd wake up,
it'd be like,
did somebody just get killed in the other room?
But if you're,
if you're like a normal sleeper,
Cleo,
you can't scratch the whole podcast.
All right now God dammit,
you weren't scratching it all before he started.
And the second this thing comes on,
you just lay on the wires.
Come here.
Do you have any concept of,
of a podcast?
Do you,
you can't just lay on the mixer.
You're just looking at me like,
can you fucking start rubbing my belly here?
What,
what are we trying to do here?
Um,
all right,
so let me,
and let me get to my favorite fucking thing I've read in a long time.
Uh,
clearly you've got to get off the wires.
It's my fault.
They called you up.
I love you buddy.
But you could,
you gotta go.
Do you want get over there?
Yeah,
go on.
Go see mommy.
Go on.
I love that.
She knows what that means.
All right.
I gotta read this fucking thing here.
All right,
so the Ryder Cup is like a,
I dunno what it is.
I fucking hate golf.
I don't hate it.
I like smoking cigars.
I like getting drunk,
but I just,
I can't fucking,
I can eat the fucking assholes stand over the ball for like nine hours.
You're going to slice it.
Just fucking hit the thing.
And didn't drop another one and they all fucking,
she won't talk about fucking cheaters.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Yeah.
I,
I hit a six six.
What?
Fucking lost balls.
You asshole.
We fucking saw you whacking at it.
Yeah.
One of my favorite things to do when it golf is I count every fucking stroke.
If I'm on the fucking,
if I'm teeing off,
whatever the fuck you call it.
All right.
If I swing and miss,
I count that fucking thick because people would od.
No,
no,
no.
I was trying.
That counts.
You cheat and con,
you know others so much cheating and fucking golf because the people generally
speaking who play it or not fucking athletic.
He got a lot of bankers.
You got a lot of stuff,
shirts.
You've got a lot of people are just motivated by fucking money.
They will never picked a gym class.
Okay.
They had their underwear yanked up over their fucking head and it had this anger
in him.
I'm going to show up some day when I come back to the fucking high school
reunion.
I'm going to have this fucking unbelievable car or whatever the fuck it is that
deal.
Or maybe they're born into money.
Well maybe I'm just completely full of shit and I don't like the sport because I
am I my legs a white like the mood,
so to Allah,
maybe that's what it is.
But anyways,
I've been telling you guys that I,
I really like wearing golf clothes that's so fucking comfortable.
It's breathable and moveable because there's so many fat fucking,
unless athletic fucks that play that game and they've got to walk around.
Who's Kitten,
who they get the golf cart and they want to look to their fucking ball.
You know what I mean?
They got all this shit,
this stoop there.
Fucking socks matches as striping their color,
right?
They get the baggy shit on and you know then when they go,
when they go fucking,
when they go back with the club and they got to move that dead fucking mush of
man tits and belly underneath that shirt,
you know what I mean?
Like,
like the way you lat is or where their lat should be.
Right.
There's all this,
this said,
it's all marbled and that shirt has to fucking stretch.
Right?
So because of those fucking people complaining to the clothing companies like
that,
I'm telling you,
the shit is crazy.
How comfortable is,
I love it.
My wife hates it.
So anyways,
silhouette the Ryder Cup is basically when the Americans play.
I Dunno,
we,
I guess we played Great Britain and,
and somebody else who gives a fuck about golf.
It's country versus country.
It's like the Olympics,
except nobody really gives a shit.
Right?
Um,
I know people care,
right?
So anyways,
there's some fucking a guy Danny will it and he has a brother and his brother
just went off on Americans.
The American fans.
It's fucking hilarious.
And I guess of course it's some big goddamn controversy because somebody had the
nerve to call Americans.
You know,
I don't,
I've never understood why,
why you can't do that or why if,
if somebody,
if your brother says something fucked up and you're in the public eye,
all of a sudden you have to answer for it.
Like,
this guy was like stammering,
like apologizing for the guy.
I'd be like,
who said it?
Your brother?
I whoa.
Who said the thing that's your upset?
Who said it?
My brother.
Right?
Yeah.
Well fucking go talk to him yet.
Can't
the fuck.
Um,
and why can't they say that?
Why can't they say that and why does that make the sport lose fans?
You know what I mean?
You know why?
Cause there's fucking kids in the world.
Oh my kid heard that.
Well Daddy,
you know what else he heard?
[inaudible] you fucking your wife the other night.
All right.
That's his mother.
What do you think that did to him?
What are the way I think was worse?
No,
Jesus.
Bill,
I'm always grabbing when I,
when I fly that day.
All right,
here we go.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
so I guess they're,
they're playing each other and uh,
I guess we play in England in golf or some shit.
Like anybody gives a fuck.
I guess a lot of people give a fuck,
but I don't,
so I assume no one else does because I'm a,
I'm self centered.
So anyways,
his brother was texting with somebody.
I,
this is once again,
I don't know how somebody found this,
if it was a fucking email or whatever.
Well,
when I read for Danny will,
Ed was quietly going about his business during a Ryder Cup practice round
Wednesday morning when all hell was breaking loose on social media,
thanks to escaping scathing screen.
His brother wrote for a website in which she called Americans fat,
stupid,
greedy,
classless bastards.
You know what I love about that?
That guy,
he just hit the nail on the head.
Can we honestly,
can we fucking argue any of that?
Generally speaking,
come on,
let's go through a fat.
You got us stupid.
We go,
you know,
I'll give you that greedy.
Absolutely classless bastards to totally 100 fucking percent.
Dude.
This guy's insults on the fucking golf fans that show up to this thing.
It's like when Larry Bird would just be doing the three point contest and he
just kept shooting him through the net,
you know?
And when he ends it with classless bastards,
that's the two point ball.
The colored one in the end.
Dude,
I read this thing like the headline says,
family few.
Well we'll let's brother,
however the fuck you say his name.
It just says Colon Americans,
fat,
stupid,
greedy bastards.
And I was on the plane and I burst out laughing and I was like,
please let this article be as much of a joy to read as the headline.
And it was,
he said,
the
man,
here we go,
stupid.
I can't even say this word.
The excoriating of American golf surely was not a part of Darren Clark's
captains handbook,
part of which states the visiting team shall not rile up the opposition's home
crowd.
Would trash talk.
Uh,
these were some of the choices of his words in the article.
I got to read this fucking article.
This is what he said.
For the Americans to stand a chance of winning,
they need their bang mob of imbeciles.
Okay.
The only thing that could make this funny is listening to this guy say it in an
English accent.
This is the greatest shit I've written a while to get there.
Bang mob of imbeciles to caress their egos every step of the way.
Team Europe east to shut those groupies up.
They need to silence the pudgy basement dwelling irritants stuffed on cookie
dough and pissy bear.
Pausing between mouthfuls of hotdogs so they can scream Baba booey until they're
jelly faces turned red.
It just keeps going.
They need to stun the angry unwashed,
make America great again.
Swarm desperately gripping their concealed carry con compensators and belting
out a mini belting out a mini erection inducing mash potato hoping to impress
their cousin.
Uh,
they need to smash the obnoxious dads with their shiny teeth.
Lego man hair medicated ex wife and resentful children.
Oh my God.
If I wasn't so lazy,
I'd give this guy a standing ovation.
How do you get mad?
I mean,
how do you get when a guy goes dead heart?
How the fuck do you get mad at that?
I mean,
that's hilarious.
C'Mon man.
You can get,
and then I'll,
you could do the same thing about them that they're fucked up.
Teeth of fet.
Fucking fish and chip Eaton jackasses,
Neo Nazi fucking racist.
Beating the fuck out of each other at their fucking stupid ass pussy.
Fucking football games.
You can't use your hands.
Everybody flopping around the ground.
Dude,
soccer is such a Shitty fucking sport.
Women's soccer is actually better than the men's.
Alright,
and I'm just talking legit.
I don't mean like volleyball because they're fucking hot.
Dude.
Look at the fucking ass on her.
I'm not looking at them even remotely,
even objectifying them.
I'm just saying straight up as a sport.
The fucking ladies play.
Somebody trips them.
They get up.
These fucking guys are rolling around on the ground.
Oh my God.
It's,
it's fights.
It's like watching musical theater without the fucking music.
It's horrific there.
So I did that.
Now does,
does,
does my brother have to apologize to me?
Fucking standing ovation.
What the fuck?
I got to give that guy a shout up.
Not to Danny,
because Danny then for some reason he has to,
you know,
he left his fucking balls off in,
in some really comfortable clothes golfing close.
He must have been laughing at his fucking ass off and just be like,
dude,
why the fuck did you do that to me?
Uh,
he just goes,
ah,
I just,
after that fucking masterpiece,
all right,
whether you agree with it or not,
that was a fucking Lego man.
Hair are pissy beer.
Come on.
The FDA fucking,
uh,
concealed carry.
Compensators
um,
okay.
And then this is what he says,
you know,
off the record,
he laughed his balls off and then on the record he's just like,
uh,
I just like to apologize to everyone involved.
Uh,
I spoke to him on the phone after and I was made aware after I was made aware of
what was being said and I said to Peter,
I was obviously disappointed at what we said and what was written about the
American fans.
Uh,
they took me under their wing fantastically back in April,
I guess when he won the masters.
And as soon as they got off the golf course,
I went to see Davis and me and Davis had a chat for a few minutes about it all.
Uh,
a took a really well and he's at did,
we took it really well.
They fucking laugh and their balls off and you know what's funny is then they
get,
they got a picture of,
of the American fans,
you know,
and these f there's three people in the photo and there's not one of them that I
would not go out and get shit faced with.
We need these,
the these,
yeah,
these are the fucking people you need those people.
These are the people who they're not going to do anything in life.
They're going to watch other people do shit in life and go fucking nuts.
Right.
When you accomplish something and when you don't,
they're going to say you suck and talk a bunch of shit about what they would
have done.
Right.
Who Doesn't love being that guy?
They're all draped in the fucking,
one guy's dressed like uncle Sam,
another guy,
for whatever reason,
he has an an American flag shirt and that he has like a park ranger hat on.
Maybe that's a golf thing and the other guy has got the fucking,
he's got the American flag over his head while wearing a baseball hat.
He looks like an,
he looks like an old woman.
Like when Shit,
like he's wearing like a shawl or something.
Oh that's fucking late.
And there's nothing better to the dumber.
The fans are at a golf event when they were around pros.
That's one of my favorite things.
You know what I mean?
Cause you just said every everything about like tennis and golf is Shh,
shh.
Like stop talking shit.
You know what I mean?
It's fucking the fucking NBA.
You're going to take a fucking foul shot.
Like a third of the stadium is,
is doing everything but taking their dicks out and shaking it in your face and
these guys can consistently make it.
How about a little focus?
Tennis is the same way.
Quiet please.
You know what I mean?
They don't boo they whistle.
Oh,
speaking of which,
there's a fucking incredible documentary out there about,
uh,
Serena Williams last year when she tried to do the Serena Slam,
I mean she won four in a row.
Mean she won the US Open,
but it was in 2014 and then she won the Australian,
then she went French.
And then she won the Wimbledon.
So that's four in a row right there.
She did it the way tiger woods did it,
like four majors went by.
And,
but I guess,
but Serena Williams,
actually that's three one,
sorry.
I Steffi Graf actually did it.
And somebody else,
I forget her fucking name actually,
I believe.
I haven't looked it up in a while,
but I believe that they did it in a calendar year.
So I'll give him that one.
But when they will break and tiger woods balls,
give me a fucking break.
Nobody's even come close to doing that and he fucking,
he won four in a row.
So whatever.
And if you'd read Andre Agassi's book open,
which even if you're not into sports,
which I don't think anybody left listening to this podcast is not into sports
after this fucking shit.
Um,
that's all I've been talking about this week.
if you read his book,
it's one of the best books I've ever fucking red as far as like a,
an autobiography.
It's,
um,
it's
like I fucking hate reading.
I get add out the fuck.
I got a,
I guess a mild form of dyslexia and I'm a fucking moron.
So I mean,
I've got a lot work and against me.
All right?
And I was riveted reading that book.
Totally fucking engaging.
And uh,
if you've actually read that book and then you watch the Serena documentary,
just like the gist of what that sport does to your body and shit,
it's fucking how half the fucking thing is her laying on a table getting a
massage.
You know,
they'll probably just sounded all creepy,
but I'm seriously,
you read the Odyssey thing and the guy sitting and talking about he,
he's taking like a fucking hour long shower,
try to get his body to be able to move again when he's just played the first
round of a major and he's got to somehow fight his way through that and getting
shot up with shit.
It's fucking unbelievable.
But,
um,
it's a,
it's a great,
great fucking documentary.
And,
uh,
you got to love the documentaries because my wife will not watch sports,
you know,
but if there's a documentary about it,
like a 30 for 30,
you know,
documentaries bring people together,
like I won't watch real housewives,
but if they did a documentary on one of them and how the fuck they ended up on
that,
you know,
that it would be interesting.
You are an absolute fucking failure if you'd,
if you make a document and uninteresting documentary.
I'm trying to think the last time I ever saw
a documentary that wasn't on sub level.
Interesting.
Like you're literally fucking watch somebody like a,
hey,
this is how they make a milk bottles.
Uh,
you know,
the,
uh,
the what,
whatever the fuck you call it.
The,
the way we go about making it,
whatever that big word is,
the process that's not that big.
That's a medium board bill as she has not changed.
It's remained the same for hundreds of years and they're just,
you just go,
I go down a fucking rabbit hole just watching that shit.
Tom Papa the Great Tom Papa fucking,
um,
made me a loaf of bread meat.
Like,
who's kidding,
who we made it for?
Nia.
Nia was the one asking for it,
right?
Tom Doesn't give a shit about me.
The man uses me,
you know,
comes over here.
He smokes all my cigars,
he drinks all my liquor.
Totally joke at Tom's,
one of one of the great human beings I've ever met.
Um,
he's a great guy and he made it for both of us cause he's a sweetheart.
And um,
so he was telling me this whole thing about how,
you know how you make sour sour dough bread like the old fashioned way and how
this,
the yeast bacteria is in the air and you make like this concoction of like
flower cause yeast eats flower and you mix it with water and you got to leave it
out.
And then when it starts to like for a couple of days and then when it bubbles
up,
you know it's going to start to smell like beer and you know,
and if he didn't fuck it up,
you know,
once it gets to a certain point out of the year,
you put like plastic wrap and sick,
this whole fucking process just to get this thing called your starter so you can
get the fucking sourdough taste in there,
I guess.
And,
and that,
that concoction is one of the most disgusting things I've ever seen in my life.
MMM.
And you just,
you just eat,
it's fucking unreal because once you make it,
you just keep feeding it and it keeps living.
And evidently in France,
did they have the,
these,
these concoctions that somebody started the starter or the,
or mother,
they call it mother,
which is really creepy.
MMM.
Like they started at like a hundreds of years ago,
like a hundred years ago,
somebody started it and they just kept passing it down and people just kept
feeding the fucking thing.
It's really,
it's fucking bizarre.
But that shit,
like if there was a documentary on making bread,
I would sit down and I would,
I would watch,
you know?
But if there was a fucking Sitcom about people that made bread,
I would fucking take a gun out.
I wouldn't kill myself,
but I would want to,
you know what I mean?
Why do I always go to suicide?
Does anybody else think?
I just always think that.
I just always think about like,
yeah,
you know,
I could,
I could either sit through this or I could,
I could dive under that passing bus.
I'm not going to do it.
Hey,
would you do it if you absolutely fucking knew without a Debbie weird,
if you knew without a that there was,
there was a better place.
You know what I mean?
If you knew without a doubt there was a better place than you would go into it.
Like you gotta you gotta be thinking back.
This does to had to be a couple of events.
You know,
we just select Jesus.
I got this paper due,
I'm with this girl,
I got to break out.
I don't a fucking break up with her,
you know,
it's just all right.
That was dark.
Okay,
let's,
let's get out of that.
You should never do that.
It's not an option.
There's always hope,
you know,
you know what's a great thing?
You don't want to get you out of a depression.
You get a dog,
you get a dog like mine that'll put you in a happy mood.
Dogs are the fucking best.
You know,
you come home that just,
I know every comic has done a bit on this,
but they're just so fucking psyched to see it.
They're always fucking psyched to see you can never disappoint them.
You know what I mean?
They just love you.
They're the best.
You know,
the other night,
you know,
when I was,
I was fucking a,
I hate to move my car,
right?
Um,
and it was like,
you know,
street cleaning day,
so it was opposite side of the fucking street parking.
So,
you know,
I'm like,
God damn.
And I went to drive like 15 minutes down the fucking road or some shit.
Right.
And my dog was already asleep,
but because it hurt me going outside,
it immediately got up and was looking at me like,
oh,
how are we going out together and going out?
And I was looking like,
not,
not just fucking just moving the car,
relax dude.
So I go out there,
I drive down the street and it was like a 15 minute walk back.
Took me a couple of minutes to drive over there.
So I was gone like 1520 minutes.
I come back to the house,
my wife's already in bed,
she's already in bed.
She's not concerned about me.
Right.
The lights are all off in the house.
I opened the door quietly and who's fucking sitting right there still waiting
for me.
My dog still fucking waiting for me.
And I just looked at the thing.
I was just saying,
yeah,
you know,
and it didn't,
and the it wagging its tail and I locked the door and then it walked with me
down the stairs to go to bed.
It was like,
it was like a body guard.
It's,
you know,
hey,
I'm telling you,
they're the fucking best.
Having said that,
some fucking lady on my flight
on my way out,
like,
dude,
this whole,
um,
I need my dog,
cause I'm afraid to fly.
Fucking thing is getting out of control.
Like the size of dog that you can bring on.
This person brought on a dog that was like a,
the next weight class up from a cocker spaniel in a poor husband like is
bringing the,
the,
the whole fucking doggy bed.
And I'm thinking going,
are they really thinking they're going to stick that in between the rows?
And they didn't,
they jammed it in the overhead compartment.
Like the two of them took up an entire rows,
overhead compartment,
just fucking selfish cons.
And every time I,
you know,
she'd walked by with the dying and looker,
she do that smile like,
isn't it adorable?
Oh yeah,
the dog is adorable.
You're not,
you know,
you're a selfish fuck.
That's what I was thinking.
But then you know what,
the dog was totally well behaved and it wasn't a fucking problem.
And of course they sat in the row right in front of me and um,
I dunno,
I don't know.
You know,
I,
I got to learn to let shit go.
I really did.
I actually,
I'm trying right now,
two things I'm trying to do.
All right,
not flip out when I drive and not get mad at technology.
If I could do that I would yell 80% less and uh,
I think my wife would,
would,
would enjoy her life a lot more,
you know?
All right,
well I've got to pause here to uh,
to read some advertising.
I don't even know if it's come in yet.
And then I got to read the questions for this week.
Um,
by the way,
congratulations to the fucking buffalo bills.
They've been looking great the last two weeks.
You know,
all you guys,
all the Buffalo Bill faithful out there,
you were ready to kick rex to the fucking curb.
A lot of you were right.
Like he was going to turn around that shit show in a couple of games.
He's a fucking damn good coach that and I don't know,
I don't know what his record is against Belicheck but he's got to be the closest
to 500.
If anybody.
I mean,
Tom Claflin is the guy that owns bell a check,
you know,
he's the guy that when they all fucking hang out in the end,
Bill's going to sit there and laugh and go on.
Yeah.
And how are you guys all game here after,
but this guy,
this motherfucker right here.
This guy's the guy.
Um,
all right.
Uh,
let's see if I got the fucking advertising.
[inaudible] come on,
give me the advertising one time.
One time,
six 24.
Where the fuck is it?
And nothing.
All right,
I got to hit pause.
It ain't going to be a big deal in your life.
It's just going to be a couple of seconds.
All right,
Bill,
give my dog a fucking flea bath.
All right.
What's wrong with you?
I love you too.
Okay?
Okay.
All right.
I'm back.
Just like dad,
just like debt.
Um,
of course I didn't fucking,
yeah,
why would I turn it on until I get the hang on a fucking second.
Okay.
And I'm back again.
All right.
Fuck God damn is hot as shit.
Oh Shit.
Gimme the loot crate.
Hey,
you're fucking nerds.
You're looking for gear,
collectibles,
housewares,
and more from your favorite pop culture franchises.
We got you covered.
Loot crate offers a range of Geek and Gamer items for less than 20 bucks a
month.
Want to bring you a loot to the next level?
Get a bigger box with even bigger loop with loot crate DAX.
Uh,
does that mean to you that the sizes are bigger?
You get more shit?
It's probably get more shit.
You know,
it's gotta be that's gotta suck,
man.
If you're in,
there's so many people that are into superheroes that aren't and aren't even
remotely in shape.
And you know,
you want to dress up like him.
Come on,
nerds.
Fucking sign up for Luke rate and join a God Damn Gym,
right?
Get an aqua aqua man fucking shape today before your orange shirt arrives.
Loot crate DXC.
If you're more the type to where,
uh,
your geeky heart on your sleeve,
then Luke,
where our monthly
wearables and accessory subscription is,
the droid you're looking for,
um,
that she'll running up your spine is into your imagination.
People.
It's loot crates,
October theme horror.
We're taking over 40 years of creepy.
Can't be bloody icons and putting them in this month's crate.
Channel your best final girl with items from the walking dead nightmare.
All the walking dead nightmare on elm street.
Friday the 13th,
Texas chainsaw massacre and Halloween,
uh,
you have until the 19th at 9:00 PM Pacific to subscribe and receive this month,
that month's crate.
And when the cutoff happens,
then it,
that's it.
It's over.
All right?
So make sure to head over to www dot [inaudible] dot com crate with the c a
slash burr and enter burr to say $3 off any new subscription today.
And it ends with saying boom.
All right,
AH,
dollar shave club,
everybody.
Guys,
you know to go to dollar shave club for a fest,
fantastic shape.
Evidently you know that what you probably don't know is that they have other
amazing products.
All right?
They're going to push this shit on you to seek and look nice and dulled up when
you go out on the fucking town.
The quality is the best on the market.
Their body wash is great and won't dry out your skin.
They're pre and post shave stuff keeps your skin soft and smooth.
This stuff we'll have you looking and smelling like 1 million bucks.
This is great.
They're going to give you all fucking hooked up.
Now you don't have to go into cvs buying all your shit right,
and you just go in the goddamn website.
You just knock it all out,
right?
Next thing you know,
somebody shows up and the shaving your balls,
this stuff we'll have you looking and smelling like 1 million bucks.
Dollar Shave club's got stuff for your hair.
You feel your face feel and departs for everywhere to keep you feeling and
looking fresh.
Once you're in the club,
you'll see they've got the best grooming products out there and they're all
affordable right now.
Your chance to see right now is your chance to see for yourself why so many
people love dollar shave club.
I just love dollar shave club just brightens up the room.
You're not a member.
If you're not a member yet and you've never joined,
now's the time.
You'll get your first month of razors for absolutely free.
Just pay shipping and Atlanta and that's not fucking Frey.
Now is it?
And that's it.
That's after.
After that,
it's only for a few bucks.
Join today.
Go to dollar shave club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr oh and as our favorite go to a law about Oh
bull bull me undies beyond deeds to pat sa three and one Badu to to be undies me
undies.
That suspension was a lot of fun.
We won three games.
We only lost one.
Put on the underwear.
Now you've got fun floss in your crotch.
Given the finger to fuck a gym are say yeah,
that's if he's sober.
Um,
all right.
Picture a world where putting on a new pair of underwear.
Three one day,
Tommy's coming back.
He's coming the fucking Cleveland Kid,
the fucking town and five Billy Bella.
Check.
Um,
what else?
Jesus Christ.
And You keep the thing.
Cleveland fans have the fucking nerve to bitched.
Well,
I guess they should bitch.
They didn't make that decision.
Did they?
And he wasn't winning when he was there.
I guess he kinda dead.
Okay.
I Dunno.
Anyways,
me undies.
Picture a world where putting on a new pair of underwear,
it isn't just fresh.
You're stepping into a better day.
Jesus Christ and relax.
It's just fucking underwear.
Think about it.
Where's the first thing he put on and the last thing you take off,
unless you're fucking weird,
unless you're weird.
One of those people put their shirt on first and just sitting there with get
junk.
Hang in there.
Um,
why would you settle for anything less than the best feeling underwear on the
planet?
Uh,
please include all of the falling plot I'm going to fucking include over the
euro.
Deek.
Mandy's focuses solely on producing the most comfortable underwear you've ever
experienced.
My friends at me,
Andy sent me at for a few pairs a while back and now I can't imagine wearing
anything else.
It makes each and every day that much better.
That's my bad men.
Most western accent.
Get yourself a brat and watch the badgers.
Um,
for the price of two cocktails,
a Mandy's will deliver you.
You're new.
Did they just send,
they send me a few.
It actually did send me a few pairs.
Um,
one of them I liked and then the other one was just too fucking small.
And I look like a pasty Addis shape.
Greg Louganis.
Okay.
Meaning it was as tight as a speedo.
I would never say I was as good looking guy is Greg Louganis.
Alright.
For the price of two cocktails me undies,
we'll deliver your favorite pair of underwear right to your doorstep.
Better Day guarantee.
Try them on.
And if they aren't the most comfortable,
best feeling undies you've ever had,
they'll refund you and let you keep your first pair for free.
Included in the prices to sweet touch of modelle rouse,
a s a special fabric made with the best in class raw materials that are
scientifically proven to be three times softer than cotton.
That means when they were doing it right,
they'd have,
somebody would have a handful of cotton and somebody would have a handful of
modal modal,
right?
And they'd walk up to a naked man and they would just start rubbing his under
and he's blindfolded.
Which one you like?
Oh,
you like the my,
well,
how much?
How many times better is it?
Uh,
you know,
I'd say that twice as good.
The font,
that's not good enough.
Anyways,
these,
how do they figure that shit out?
Okay.
These Uber Cozy undies are sold exclusively on me on these website while you're
on joy free shipping in the u s and Canada and for a limited time,
everyone in my audience and wherever else they fucking advertise gets 20% off
their first order.
But you have to go to our,
our special URL,
me undies.com/burr with the me undies.
Better Day guarantee you have nothing to lose.
So don't wait any
longer.
Go to me undies.com/bar right now for 20% off your first order.
That's [inaudible] dot com slash bar.
Can you imagine if you put on those unbelievably comfortable underwear,
right?
And then something makes you laughed and you shit yourself a little bit.
I mean,
that would ruin your day,
you know,
and I bet you couldn't send those back.
TCIS bill is Skidmark Joe by,
it's a little late in the podcast.
What do you want from me?
All right.
stamps.com this is the last one.
Everybody mailing and sh mailing and shopping are a routine part of your,
of running your business.
Important.
Keeps important.
Keeps your operation going.
I never will get that fucking sentence outright.
Mailing and shipping are a routine part of your sick of running your business.
dot.dot.
Important Comma keeps your operation going.
How the fuck am I supposed to read that?
Mailing and shipping are a routine part of running your business.
Important.
Oh,
so important.
Keeping your operation going.
Oh,
that's it.
They're doing the.dot,
dot.
Oh,
I see.
You want the and so forth and so on.
Read.
Okay,
let's do this again.
Take 200 a stamps.com mailing and shipping are a routine part of running your
business.
Important.
Keeps your operation going.
That didn't work.
Important.
Fucks the whole thing up.
I'm not saying it anymore.
Importance off the fucking roster.
I don't give a shit.
Okay.
You want me to cook the dinner?
You've got to let me buy the groceries.
Uh,
but if you're making,
who knows who's that about?
Everybody come up.
Pats.
Fans.
What?
Who,
who said it and what player was he talking about in three,
two,
one bang.
Bill Parcells,
Terry Glenn,
who did he say to Robert Craft?
Um,
if,
but if you're making constant trips to the post office,
that's a routine you need to change.
There's a much more convenient way.
stamps.com stamps.com brings all of the service of the post office right to your
desk.
You'll never waste valuable time going to the post office again so you can focus
on what really matters growing your business.
Trying to fuck the chick next door.
I use stamps.com whenever I sell post is after my shows.
I'm going to be selling an exclusive poster at the end of my fucking run in DC
every night after the show and I'll be using stamps.com to get those
motherfuckers there right now.
Sign up for stamps.com and use my last name bur for this special fucking four
week trial plus $110 bonus offer,
including a postage and digital scale.
They've had this special offers since I've been reading this for five fucking
years.
It's not special.
We've been doing this forever.
It's as special as a comedy central special,
um,
half hour,
the half hour special.
Um,
don't wait.
Go to stamps.com.
Before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirdthatstamps.com enter
burr.
All right,
now we're on to the questions.
We're on to the questions yet that,
that,
that to,
to,
um,
while you guys asked me for advice.
I know why,
because you just want to hear me read out loud.
I know it is.
I know you'd have to take it seriously.
And uh,
anybody takes this seriously.
You're your own.
This is a disclaimer.
All right.
Why would you take advice from me and went to summer school to what a four years
in high school should have gone all for my sophomore teacher hooked me up,
gave me the d minus and senior year.
It was like,
what's the point?
Evidently I have to learn a trade.
All right.
Comic book stuff.
Uh,
dear Billy,
unbreakable.
We all know how you hate comic con stuff.
I actually,
I don't,
I don't it,
they're just,
they're an easy target and I'm lazy.
You know what I mean?
I Dunno.
I,
although I had recently watched some reality,
I was on a plane,
right?
It was on the planes,
it plain.
And,
uh,
there was some show and it was just these guys standing around in,
um,
oh,
what the fuck is a comic book store out here?
And I started to watch it and they were all doing that fucking,
if this comic guy,
comic book guy fought that Comic Book Guy.
And I can't,
I can't sit through that,
but I could sit through dude,
who is better Gretzky?
Lemieux uh,
Talon.
You've Loomio didn't have those years off.
I will.
I'll,
I'll fucking stay in that forever.
Uh,
but I,
you know,
I,
I can't get into the competition as much as,
you know,
I like the superheroes when I was growing up,
but then,
you know,
I got older and die a,
I grew up,
alright.
Superhero movies and loot crate.
I don't hate that shit.
I just like making fun of it.
He said,
you've mentioned in the past,
the only superhero you liked was Luke cage,
Aka power man.
No,
I like Spiderman to captain America.
Iron Man.
Batman was cool more.
The comic book on TV was,
you know,
I'd like that show when I was younger,
but then it was just sort of silly to can't be for me.
Um,
I like the Heath Ledger Batman and I loved that Christian Bale.
You know,
even everybody made fun of his voice.
It,
it fucking made sense that he would change the sound of his fucking voice.
You know,
you guys know what my voice sounded like.
Fight a three quarter fucking mask on and I just started talking to you.
You'd be like,
to what?
The fucks with the mass bill,
you know.
Anyways.
Uh,
well,
okay.
Your should be,
you should be excited to know he has his own Netflix series.
Now get the fuck Outta here.
Luke cage does.
It's super popular and getting attention,
not just because it's great,
but also because it's topical.
It knowingly acknowledges the significance of a bullet proof African American
wearing a Hoodie,
uh,
through the series.
Luke engages with police offers who shoot him and leave holes in these hoodies.
The police often interrogate and harass black people in Harlem who have done
nothing wrong.
Oh,
I gotta watch that.
He goes,
my questions are,
do you still like Luke cage?
Will you watch the series?
Yes.
Do you think it's good to acknowledge Trayvon Martin and the black lives matter
movement in this way?
Yeah.
Why not?
When you watch those fucking,
those Pixar movies,
they talk about global warming.
You know,
they had the ant thing and they go know one answer is not top,
but you got to fall the edge,
start moving.
They could take us over.
That was all about like the fucking Bilderberg people.
If they can do all of that shit,
why can't they bring up that stuff?
I love it.
Is that,
is that a good way to acknowledge is first of all,
who the fuck am I to say that that's not an issue?
That,
that,
uh,
that has made my life like,
I don't have to worry about my life,
you know what I mean?
So I would ask,
why don't you ask black people that?
Do you think it's good to acknowledge?
Anyways,
I love your podcast and you stand up a greetings from Ontario.
Um,
yeah.
I'm just like,
that's,
I mean I like when,
uh,
I like 'em as much as I should.
I've,
I liked superman versus Batman.
All right.
I like when they do the comic book stuff and as much as like,
you know,
the people can fly in their fucking,
the size of an ant and shit like that,
the more reality that they bring into it,
the more grounded that they keep it.
The more I like it.
And I know superman versus fucking Batman.
They're like,
Geez,
how many people did they fucking kill?
That never entered my mind.
I didn't give a shit.
They're like,
they did billions of dollars with the damage.
Who gives a fuck?
My favorite thing was,
were saying that superhero can't,
they can't be out there acting unilaterally.
Like,
they didn't like that superman was going around,
just helping everybody,
regardless of,
uh,
you know,
whether they would trade with the United States or not.
And I just love that the United States felt that they could claim superman was
fucked up.
I guess he got adopted by United States parents that he did get a free
education.
Yeah.
What the fuck are you doing?
You know what,
I stand by the American government on that one.
Um,
yeah,
no,
but the more that they can bring in like the,
uh,
just to real world reality,
I think that that shit's great.
And the dark,
I mean,
in the comic books,
it isn't always like dark depressing.
They're fucking loners.
Like I never liked the x man thing.
It just sounded like a bunch of whiny teenagers to me.
They didn't go dark enough or make it adult enough.
It was probably for teenage kids.
Who's kidding who,
um,
it probably wasn't for a fucking bald 48 year old male.
We got to get these guys these,
this is our demographic.
They,
these are the guys that are going to buy all the fucking swag.
Um,
I actually,
uh,
when I was a kid,
I read comic books and I really liked the drawings in the different ways that
they would go about it.
And when,
when,
you know,
sometimes they take up a whole page and they draw something or they'd have like
three of the squares would all like a bullet got shot and they just show where
it went and stuff.
Like,
I really liked it and I thought it was incredibly talented and that thing,
but I stopped short of,
uh,
like dressing up like them and having like a fucking light saber fight,
you know what I mean?
Um,
I guess that's where you lose me and,
you know,
to be honest with you,
what I'm doing this with a lot of people do is,
um,
I'm taking like,
you know,
most golf fans are not like those fucking animals at the Ryder Cup screaming and
yelling like a bunch of fucking lunatics,
you know.
I mean,
a lot of them are,
uh,
you know,
I went to the masters people that people will fucking cool,
but it's just,
it's just fun to make fun of them.
I guess
Jesus built,
did you retract everything that you've ever said about it?
Uh,
sort of.
I'm trying,
I'm trying to be a better fucking person,
man.
I got to stop.
Like I just that the word content and all this stuff,
they just flies out of me in public and it's getting worse.
And uh,
you know,
it's gotten to the point where now it actually,
for the first time in my life,
like embarrasses me.
So I'm trying to see the other side of that.
And I know people are like,
well,
Jen,
you now could it be funny anymore?
Believe me,
I will fuck up plenty of my life.
I don't need to be screaming cunt when there's children around in a fucking
airport.
All right.
Montreal pit bull ban.
I bill,
I think you're special.
Let it go.
Did a lot to educate people about what sweet and loving pets pit bulls can be.
I don't have a pit bull myself,
but I do not believe in breed specific legislation or banning certain breeds of
dog just because they're more likely to be owned by assholes who will train them
to be violent.
I live in Ontario where pitbulls are already banned.
Uh,
when Mark [inaudible],
How the fuck do you say that bill was in?
That was in the Toronto Blue Jays.
You mean on the Toronto Blue Jays?
He chose to live alone in Toronto,
away from his family rather than give up their pit bull.
Recently,
Montreal Council voted in favor of a bill to ban new pit bulls and other
dangerous breeds as well as PR,
impose strict regulations on pit bulls already living in the city,
including muzzling.
Oh,
putting a muzzle on them.
From what I read,
the bill seems to be a panic reaction to the death of a woman who died following
a dog attack.
Here's the article.
If you want to read it,
I would love for you to speak out against this super lame bylaw and continue to
use your fame as a platform to educate people about I.
Dude,
I don't do that.
I'm not going to be that person.
Hey,
I have a podcast now.
You should listen to me about social issues.
Um,
perceived as dangerous.
Your bit about doctrine.
Cleo is seriously one of my favorite things in life.
I'll thank you.
I wish everyone could hear it.
Thank you so much,
Bill.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Um,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
I,
I don't,
I don't know.
I don't know what the fuck happened up there,
but like,
I don't think pit bulls,
a bad dogs.
Um,
I will tell you my dog's a fucking psycho and would try to kill you if you came
into the house would attack you because it's possessive.
It's envious,
jealous,
whatever the fuck it is.
And uh,
my dog is dangerous and um,
you know,
and if I'm standing there,
I can't be like,
Cleo,
these people are fucking cool.
But I think what it is is
with my dog,
with its personality and the,
the information that I did not have access to.
Um,
and I don't have like,
like this dog,
like really,
like if this dog,
when this dog's with my fucking trainer,
like,
and it stays with him.
People come and go complete strangers coming to his house and the dog doesn't
flip up.
But with me,
it does.
I let it up on the bed.
I fucking snuggle with the thing and shit.
It thinks it's on the same level as me.
For whatever reason,
it feels like it has,
it has to run shit.
And um,
okay.
I just,
you know,
after a while,
because I'm so fucking busy,
I just had to like sort of adjust my life around the dog,
which is not another thing you're not supposed to do.
But um,
okay.
You know,
I can walk it down the street.
It doesn't go after people,
but if someone just walks up to me,
I don't know and starts talking to me,
it,
it starts barking.
It doesn't growl a show its teeth,
but it definitely considers it like a threat.
So,
um,
but this is the thing,
what I've noticed since having this dog is that there are a bunch of dogs that
do that of all breeds.
When I walked down the street and what I see rather than the dog is I see the
owner.
And,
um,
I am not a,
you know,
I made a lot of mistakes with my dog and,
um,
whenever my dog passes and I go to get another one,
I,
I don't know if I can do it,
dude.
I don't know if I can not have the dog be up on the fucking bed.
I have to be disciplined enough to do it.
I actually,
when I was in Vancouver one time,
or Seattle or some,
this woman told me like,
she doesn't let her dogs walk on the rug.
I come home,
she goes,
I don't even look at them until I set everything down there waiting for her and
waiting for my dog just gets to do whatever the fuck it wants.
And I think that that can be
okay.
You know,
a dangerous thing.
Um,
the bigger your dog is.
So,
um,
I,
I would,
I would actually say is rather than have a pit bull ban,
mmm.
What I would say is,
if you're going to get a dangerous breed in a pitbull is a dangerous breed and
all that me,
I'm not saying the dog is inherently dangerous.
I'm just saying that if your dog goes to bite somebody,
like anybody's dog can,
the level of damage that a pit bull can do versus if you get bit by a Chihuahua,
you have to understand,
you know,
you have to respect what you have.
So what I would say rather than have a pitbull ban,
mmm.
I would say,
what if people before you,
you,
you're able to have a pit bull.
You have to take an intensive course and become a fully educated,
great dog owner,
which is what I wish was available to me before I got my dog because I had to
learn all these lessons the hard way and,
you know,
trying to undo all of the shit that the dog learned as I'm leaving every other
weekend and I'm in a writer's room all day.
It,
you know,
like owning a dog is a tremendous amount of responsibilities.
So that alone,
forget about all the fucking horrible people,
human beings that are out there that do horrible fucking things to animals.
Um,
I mean,
I'm hypocritical goal because I eat chickens and cows and pigs and shit and,
uh,
you know,
they don't exactly treat them.
You know,
there was,
oh,
it's free range,
it's organic and all that shit.
And then you watch the documentary and they're cutting their beaks off and feed
them cows and shit and it's fucking horrific.
Um,
but,
but you know,
these people who fight dogs and these people who like,
you know,
I mean,
I honestly think like,
you know,
there,
there was some case in like New York with this guy just,
he was in an argument,
his girlfriend,
he snatched the girls dog out and fucking like spiked it on the ground and
killed it into the girl woman's daughter was in the other room.
And this mother Fucker,
we're only gets 60 days.
It's just like,
uh,
you know,
I just Kinda feel like somebody's big enough should have grabbed him in,
spiked him down on the kitchen floor,
and then he'd have to fucking deal with the ramifications of that rather than my
tax dollars paying 60 feign for $60 worth of free fucking meals for this guy to
be,
and some fucking halfway house,
um,
like the level of fucking anger issue that that guy has.
Like,
I mean,
that,
that is like,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
But that's,
that's,
that's really a shame.
And that's a really,
that's what they're doing up there is they're trying to protect people and they,
they're not gonna throw any money at it,
so they're just going to say,
all right,
no more of these dogs,
no more of these dogs.
Um,
that's what they're doing.
So,
uh,
you know,
but I gotta be honest with you,
getting mauled to death by a fucking pit bull.
I mean,
do you want to go out like that?
that's,
that's pretty fucking horrific.
Um,
but,
um,
and then also horrific is them then killing every other pit bull out there.
So,
uh,
that,
that would be my suggestion is that,
you know,
and if you are considering getting any dog,
I'm sure that there is,
there's things that you could go out.
Like I,
that's the number one fucking thing that I wish I did because I absolutely
fucking love animals.
I love dogs,
I fucking love him.
And,
uh,
everything that I do,
you know,
is probably wrong because the dog feels like it's on the same level as me and it
has to run shit.
And that's why people come through the door and it flips the fuck out and I have
to put the,
you know,
I just,
I just know how the dog is what I did.
I just adjusted to it.
I'm just like,
all right,
I know I'm having people over,
so I just take the dog downstairs and I just keep it in the room downstairs.
Nobody even sees the fucking thing.
Um,
that's the way I had to operate with my dog.
And,
um,
I can tell you that that's one way to do it,
but it's not the way to do it because there's that constant anxiety of thinking,
well,
what if it ever got out?
What the fuck happened?
Oh my God,
blah,
and I have to live with the guilt of someone else getting hurt.
And then I'd get the shit sued.
Autonomy.
I mean,
it's a,
it's a really serious fucking thing when you get a German shepherd,
if you get a pit bull,
if you get a doberman pincher,
if you get a fucking golden retriever and then those dogs can fucking do damage.
And the fact that you,
you just go,
oh my God,
it's cute and just take the fucking thing home.
Um,
forget about if you found it by the La River and you have no idea what the other
people did too.
What,
I mean,
I know my dog got abused.
I,
um,
I picked up my hockey stick when I first got it and I was stick handling in the
living room as you do.
Right.
And the dog immediately ran to the other side of the room.
And I was like,
oh my God,
somebody was hitting this thing with some sort of a stick.
So what I did was I just laid the hockey stick down in the middle of the room.
I went to the,
all the way on the opposite side of the room and I just,
I'd call the dog over and the dog would come over and go all the way around the
stick and then come over,
lick me on my face and I go,
I go back to bed and it would go back to its bed.
And each time it sniff to stick a little bit more,
a little bit more.
And I just baby stepped up to the point where by the end of it I could,
you know,
stick handling my garage,
with the tennis ball and shit.
And it didn't give a shit.
But,
um,
I wish I did that on other areas.
But,
uh,
I never,
once you see a dog going after somebody you never quite trusted again,
and then you have that fear and then they sense the fear and they process.
That is the fear is the person at the door and it's a fucking,
it's,
I've learned so much by fucking up.
So my next dog,
um,
I will not make those mistakes,
but,
um,
I don't think that it is a problem with the breed.
I think it's,
uh,
it's the,
the,
the size of the dog and the mistakes that I fucking made,
you know.
So anyways,
moving on.
All right.
Moving to the states.
Uh,
he barely slept peg a,
I'm a 21 year old guy from Sweden and I'm thinking about moving to the u s but I
can't decide where I've narrowed it down to three cities,
New York,
San Francisco,
and La.
Great fucking choices.
So my simple question is,
where do you think a guy in my age will have the most fun?
Uh,
and by the way,
will your new specialty on Netflix?
Yes.
It will be,
uh,
can't wait to see it in season two of F is for family.
Hope you and Neil lives continue to be great.
Well thank you.
Uh,
go fuck yourself and FTT.
I don't know what that means.
Fuck,
fuck something or other.
Um,
all right.
it depends on what you want to do.
All right.
You are going to get fucking laid in all three of those cities coming over.
They're Swedish guy.
You Go,
you can speak fucking another language in itself.
It's a fucking rap.
You could have an accent,
you know,
it's a wrap.
You're going to get laid.
It all depends on,
uh,
what type of women you're in and what kind of weather you like.
If you can deal with the winter,
I would say go to New York City.
New York City is the Paris,
the United States.
It's the best one we have
is far as like,
just culturally.
It's just fucking amazing.
Um,
San Francisco is,
is fucking unbelievable too.
Like the f the first of all,
the food in all three of these are unbelievable.
San Francisco is going to be the most expensive,
believe it or not.
Um,
all that computer money I guess is fucking ruined that city.
then New York and La is actually starting to,
you know,
get really expensive to,
um,
la brutal fucking traffic.
Uh,
there is a drought and,
uh,
what would I do?
21.
You know what,
man?
I,
I think I would go with New York just because if you want to go back and visit
it,
you're cutting out like five hours of the flight.
Um,
when you were in New York,
I would visit San Francisco in La,
you know,
uh,
but you know,
don't sleep on others,
other bunch of greats.
Madison,
Wisconsin's fucking great.
Pittsburgh's the shit.
Cleveland's coming around,
you know,
every time I go there it's getting fucking better and better.
Um,
I love all those fucking rust belt cities.
Chicago's to shit.
Nashville,
New Orleans,
there's so many fucking places to go,
so many fucking places to go.
Uh,
but I think New York is a great place.
It's a great place.
You know,
and there's a lot of liberal New York's there.
New York is there,
and they just think anything from another country,
especially,
um,
any country from Europe is just automatically better and more amazing.
So you know when you'll be a good person for them to fucking sit there shit on
the United States,
it's like,
you guys put your shoes on this way and we do it there.
Where it was like,
I was this,
my wife listens to NPR and they were sitting there talking about how in one of
those fucking,
you know,
countries over there where they have a million people on bicycles,
no one really gets fucked over by someone opening the car door into them.
You know,
when they parked because they have this thing called the fucking whatever they
opened,
they opened the door with their right hand.
So that gets them to look over their shoulder and they acted like it was just
astounding fucking achievement.
And why didn't we ever think of that?
I'll tell you why we never thought of it because no one rides a fucking bike
over here.
90% of people do not ride bicycles over there.
Everybody rides a fucking bike.
Just about,
most people can't even afford a fucking car.
They have bike lanes.
It's a part of how they grow up.
That's the only reason why.
It's like,
I never used to look for motorcycle riders until I rode a motorcycle.
And then now I always,
you know,
I creep over to the left,
let him drive along,
you know,
in between.
I always make sure I'm looking for him,
you know,
and I never did that before I wrote.
So anyways,
I'm off on a tangent here.
Okay.
Friend being taking advantage of at a fire station.
The fuck,
does this mean they're making them cook all the Chili or are we talking molested
here?
Dear Mr Burn,
a good friend of mine is trying to be a firefighter and I feel like he's totally
become their bitch and instead of being hired full time is fire department has
him hired as like a reserve or whatever and it hasn't working full time hours,
basically.
That would be nice.
But since he's a reserve,
he's literally getting paid like below minimum wage.
Uh,
he's been doing this for around a year or so,
and the department he's in definitely is understaffed.
They just don't want to make them full time because they would have to pay him
an actual salary.
Now,
I don't know anything about jobs and careers and stuff,
but I feel like he's definitely getting taken advantage of.
What should I do?
Should I tell him he's being fucked over?
We'd love to hear your opinion on the matter of love.
The podcast.
Can't wait for ups,
for family.
Go Fuck Yourself.
And when are you coming to northern California?
Um,
all right.
I would say,
uh,
I would just say to them and say,
Hey,
listen,
you know,
I know that,
I would just bring up work.
How's it going at work?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
Do they have any plans and making your fulltime anytime soon.
Listen to what he says and then just ask them,
well,
you know how,
how long,
uh,
so what are you,
what,
so what's the game plan?
Do they have,
they hinted anything about it and just see what he says.
Sometimes it's hard.
You got to let your friends learn hard lessons.
Sometimes you just got to kind of let them get fucked over.
I mean,
just bring it up,
see what the person says.
And uh,
hopefully your friend isn't like that guy in the joke,
in Goodfellas,
you know,
that just
means he's content to be a jerk.
What am I going to say that my,
my wife two times me.
Um,
yeah,
that's what I would do.
I would just bring it up.
I've had friends in those situations and uh,
you know,
that can be very difficult.
Um,
yeah,
so that's what I would do.
That's a simple one.
Just bring it up,
ask them how they're going and say,
ask them if they have any plans and then I would say,
so,
you know,
not trying to be nosy,
you'll just looking out for,
you know,
cause I want to see you succeed.
What w what is your plan then?
Because,
uh,
there are other firehouses out there where you could maybe get hired on.
All Right,
Jim Irsay guitar collection.
Oh Jesus,
my buddy Jim.
Or say,
hey Billy B.
Bender.
I was reading the guitar,
a fixed [inaudible] fixed you natl magazine this month and there was an article
article about Warren Hayes playing Jerry Garcia's guitar tiger at red rocks a
few months back.
This was the last guitar Jerry ever played live before his untimely death.
Anyways,
long story short,
the article went on to disclose jimmer say was the actual owner of the guitar.
Well that's what happens with most,
most of those instruments,
they are owned by rich people who are not musicians.
I'm not saying they're not lovers of music,
but um,
that's where it all ends up.
And then actual musicians,
they buy their own gear and then they make that gear legendary.
You know what I mean?
I was,
you know,
I did that shit.
I bought a 71 Ludwig green sparkled John Bonham fucking kit.
Like,
so then what?
Now I'm going to play like him.
That was an expensive lesson to learn,
you know.
But I know there's some other kid,
you know,
going down to fucking a pro drum shop out here in la and he's going to buy a
fucking kit that's a particular color.
And everything,
and t's going to tune them up,
or she's going to do it and they're going to have a sound and they're going to
put it together,
and then everybody's going to want that kit.
So it doesn't surprise me.
I mean,
he owns a team in the NFL.
This guy's a fucking billionaire,
right?
Um,
he said he paid $850,000 forward at auction.
And you know what's great about Jim or say money
is if he's a fucking billionaire,
all right?
Even if,
even if you fucking,
if you had,
if you had a hundred million bucks,
spending $850,000 is spending less than 1% of your fucking money.
MMM.
But if you're a billionaire,
then what is the fucking decimal point moves over?
One more.
Is that it?
Is it 0.01% less than that?
I don't know.
He said he paid in a 50,000,
40 to auction.
Not to mention,
he also owns Bob Dylan stratocaster from the Newport festival.
George Harrison's Gibson,
s g,
Jesus.
What a fucking collection.
And even prince is yellow cloud guitar.
Although I appreciate someone preserving musical history like he has as a
longtime guitarist and patriots fan,
I say fuck him for not allowing these guitars to be in the hands of musicians.
What are your thoughts?
Um,
I separate jimmer say the football loner when you start talking about his guitar
collection,
then he's just a regular person to me.
You know what I mean?
So He's just a rich guy that he's a music lover and I don't think they should
necessarily be in the hands of musicians because,
um,
I think that you should be influenced by great artists not go out and try to do
what they already did.
I think the fact that you as a musician will go out,
you know,
like I,
I,
if I was a musician,
my goal would be like,
I would want my guitar to be famous too.
Like how Stevie Ray Vaughn,
you know what John Bonham's vista light kit became famous.
Like none of the,
none of those things were famous.
No one knew what they look like until they got into the hands of those
unbelievable artists.
So,
um,
yeah,
I think that the reason,
the fact that they go for all that money and they ended up in rich people's
hands,
it's just a testament to the greatness of the musician and how music affects
people.
Even a guy who was a fucking NFL owner,
the fact that he's into the dead,
he's into George Harrison,
he's into prince,
he's into Bob Dylan.
I mean that he can't fuck with any of those influences.
The guys got good taste in music,
you know?
Um,
yeah,
but there's no magic in those guitars though.
I mean,
I could literally have Bonham's kit and I'm going to sound like a comedian
playing drums and you guys are all going to be like,
Hey,
can you get fucking knock it off?
You know what I mean?
So I don't think that the,
I think that they,
um,
they just like pieces of history now.
I think like a,
if you have like fucking Napoleon Sword,
I don't think that,
oh,
well that should be in some motherfucking dictators hands chopping somebody
fucking head off.
I mean,
I don't think so.
I just think that,
uh,
if you're into that type of shit,
which I totally am,
I'm completely into memory of bill,
but I refuse to buy any because so much of it is fake.
And also,
um,
I just have enough shit in my fucking house.
I don't need any more shit in my house.
And,
uh,
I also,
I don't want my fucking house to look like a fucking a fucking hard rock cafe.
You know what I mean?
When I got fucking Jim Morrison's fucking me undies on the wall framed,
you know,
and they'll probably some guy in it's probably jives better chance of being
jimmer say's fucking me undies and Jim Morrison.
So,
um,
yeah,
I don't begrudge him and um,
I think it's,
I think that's fucking awesome that he has it because,
uh,
well I guess then that's why musicians to put maybe,
I dunno,
there is something cool to touch the thing.
Like if you could ever like,
just hold that debt Jimmy Page,
double neck SG that he played stairway to heaven on.
If you could just fucking hold that thing and just feel like,
like I,
I think and you'd just start whispering when you had it.
Like,
oh my God,
it says he looked at John Bottom and we'll give him the nod when he was coming
out of the song,
you know?
Okay.
That was probably creepy lists and be fucking whisper the I,
I would be like that around that shit.
But I'm a man.
If you've got the fucking money,
you know they can have it.
So there you go,
man.
Go make your guitar fucking legendary and then see how much Jim are.
Say We'll pay for yours.
You know?
But then again,
you'd have to be dead.
Well,
Bob Dylan is not dead when you give it up for auction.
My dog right now is sitting just to the left of my computer.
She staring intensely at me.
She's been fed,
she's been out and everything like that.
And all that says that she wants to be let up on the couch.
And you know what?
I can't do it.
I'm going to turn it around.
I'm too weak or cameras that she's too fucking adorable.
Why is your head shaped like a fucking muscular light bulb?
You ever notice that your little bear faith?
Huh?
Why can't you be like this with company?
Why can't you see that I'm relaxed around them and then you are relaxed.
Why do you treat everybody like they're a fucking axe murderer?
Huh?
All right.
That's the podcasts.
Um,
go fuck yourselves.
And uh,
can I got to say again?
Congratulations to bill and that they're turning that fucking thing around
there.
I always liked the bills back.
I don't like their fucking fans cause I had a bad experience when I went out
there and we're a patriots hat and this they,
you know,
three fucking people when I was taking a piss pushed me fucking pussies.
Um,
but anyways,
a hell.
So I had a fucking patriots hat on in their stadium and I had my dick out.
What the fuck was I thinking?
Gimme Jesus Christ.
Why don't I just slip my own throat?
But I,
I liked him from back,
you know,
Joe Ferguson,
Oj Simpson and all those days and it was always snowing.
And,
uh,
I always like the buffalo bills from back then self.
That's what happens.
You,
you start to like a team when you're a kid,
you know,
even when they become your rival,
you don't give a fuck.
So,
uh,
psych Tom Brady's coming back and I'm just going to say a bunch of shit that I
already said.
All right,
go fuck yourselves.
And I'll check on Thursday.